a lot of people are saying when Stargate  returns if Brad Wright isn't the captain  of the ship and it isn't the main writer  that they will not watch the show  to those people I've got a question  how many artists musicians comedians do  their best work in their 60s how many of  them though do their best work in their  20s 30s and 40s when they're edgy are  more exciting  maybe it's not a bad thing that Brad  Wright is not returning to Stargate  maybe it's a good thing that somebody  knew somebody with some fresh ideas can  come in with new writers and new  producers a new exciting show that is  still the Stargate we love  whoever comes in has got to love the  franchise and Brad Wright is a  consultant would not be a bad idea  but somebody fresh and new is not a bad  idea either